GENTLEMEN WELCOME TO.
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE FOR FIRST
HEARING.
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
WE WILL LIKE IT STARTED WE DO
HAVE THE.
AUTHOR THAT IS.
WALK THEN PLEASE WHICH GIPSON.
I WILL BEGIN FIRST WITH THEM A
ROCA.
EDUARDO GARCIA HASN'T.
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
CORREO.
CHOI.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA.
HARPER PRESENT.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
MATHIS.
RUBIO.
THOUGHTLESS.
WOULD
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWO SEVEN TWO WHICH ENCOURAGE
THE CONSOLIDATION OF SMALL
MINUTES CYBILL WATER SYSTEMS
INTO LARGE SYSTEMS TO IMPROVE A
WATER SERVICE FOR CALIFORNIANS.
I WOULD LIKE TO.
THANK THE COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR TO STAFF WORKING
ON WITH ME AND MY TEAM ON THIS
BILL I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE
ARM AUTHORS. AMENDMENTS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS.
MANY RESIDENTS WITHIN THE STATE
CURRENTLY RECEIVES THEIR
DRINKING WATER OF FROM SMALL
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS THAT LACKS
RESOURCES FUNDING FROM LARGE
CAPITAL COSTS.
AND EVEN ONGOING COST TO
MAINTAIN PROM THE PROJECTS THAT
THEY HAVE
SMALL PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS
CANNOT OVERCOME THE CHALLENGES
BY CONSOLIDATING.
WITH. OTHER SYSTEMS TO AND SHE
OF ECONOMY OF SCALE TO PROVIDE
WATER SERVICES
ONE BAY AREA TO CONSOLIDATION IS
THE. COST OF HOLDING A FULL
BLOWN ELECTION TO APPROVE THE
SALE OF SMALLNESS WILL WATER
SYSTEMS UNDER EXISTING LAW.
AREN'T EVEN A SMALL CITY.
WITH THE WATER SYSTEM THAT.
HAVE ONLY TEN ON SERVICE
CONNECTIONS
WOULD ARE LIKELY TO HAVE A
CONSOLIDATION IN THE SYSTEM I'M
WITH ANOTHER. AYE ME COMPLETE
ELECTION INCLUDES ALL THE
REGISTERED VOTERS.
OF THE CITY THAT NEEDS TO BE.
PART OF THE.
OF THE VOTE BEFORE A SOUL OF
THE WATER AGENCY IS ACTUALLY
COMPLETED WHILE THE COSTS TO
HOLD OF AN ELECTION.
MAY NOT BE SIX SIGNIFICANT TO
LARGE CITIES
ARMS SMALLER CITIES HAS AN
EXPENSE OF THE TAXPAYERS.
AND ALSO THEIR COMMUNITY THIS
BILL SEEKS TO MODIFY THE
ELECTION REQUIREMENTS AND ALLOWS
CITIES.
CELL AND CONSOLIDATE THEIR SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS IF THE CITY
DETERMINES IF AGAIN THE CITY
DETERMINES THAT IT IS NOT IN
THE.
PUBLIC'S BEST INTEREST TO ALL
OPERATE A WATER SYSTEM.
THIS CHALLENGE WILL PROVIDE
MORE.
EXCUSE ME THIS CHANGE WILL
PROVIDE MORE CALIFORNIANS WERE
CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING WATER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING.
TESTIMONIES ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
A SELF INTRODUCED WHO REPRESENTS
THE.
WILLOW.
AGENCY IT ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
WATER SO SEE ASIAN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MY NAME IS WAYNE PEABODY.
AND WITH THE THE CITY OF
WILLOW'S ON THE CITY MANAGER.
ALL THE CITY OF WILLOW'S ISN'T
GOING COUNTY. WHERE THE
POPULATION WILL OVER SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE WE CONSIDERED A
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITY?
THE ENTIRE DRINKING WATER SUPPLY
IN THE CITY WILLS IS ADVERSELY
AFFECTED BY THE CHROME SIX.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE CITY
RESIDENTIAL WATER PROVIDER
CALIFORNIA WATER SERVICE COMPANY
RECEIVEDA GRANT FROM THE STATE
TO INSTALL TREATMENT OF THE
CHROME SIX TO ENSURE SAFE CLEAN
WATER FOR. TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
HOMES IN THE CITY OF WILLOW'S.
IN ADDITION TO THE RESIDENTIAL
SERVICE CONNECTIONS THE CITY OF
WILLOW'S OWNS AND OPERATES A
SMALL NUMBER OF INDUSTRIAL
CONNECTIONS OF OUR OWN SYSTEM.
BETTER OUTSIDE OF CAO WATER.
RATHER THAN RATHER THAN
INSTALLING DUPLICATE AND
EXPENSIVE TREATMENT
WE BELIEVE THE BEST AVENUE FOR
THE CITY IN THE CITIZENS OF
WILLOW'S IS TO PARTNER WITH CAL
WATER. AND HAVE THEM SUPPLY ALL
OF THE SYSTEM.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA STATURE
REQUIRES THE CITYWIDE VOTER TO
PROVE ALL OF THE TRANSACTIONS.
WHICH COULD RESULT IN UP TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OF AN
ELECTION COSTS FOR THE CITY.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS NOT
REASONABLE FOR A LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY.
WE WHEN THE SALE MAKES COMPLETE
SENSE HELPED ENSURE SAFE CLEAN
WATER AND DOES NOT DIRECTLY
AFFECT THE CITIZENS OF LOS.
THE WILL OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FULLY SUPPORTS AB TWO SEVEN TWO
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE SALE OF
OUR WATER SYSTEM IS TECHNICALLY
AND FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE. AND
HELPS GUARANTEE THE SAFE CLEAN
WATER FOR OUR CITIZENS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
ILLEGALLY YES.
OF THE A GOOD MORNING A MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON MY NAME'S
JACK HAWKS.
SORRY ABOUT MY VOICE.
EXECUTIVE RECORD CALIFORNIA
WATER SITUATION ARE GROUP.
REPRESENTS THE.
PUBLIC WATER UTILITIES ARE
REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
WE WERE VERY FORTUNATE THE BE
PART OF THE A WORKING GROUP.
THAT IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER A GIPSON
PUT TOGETHER.
TO.
EXAMINE LEGISLATIVE OPTIONS.
WITH RESPECT A CONSOLIDATION
THAT WOULD.
HELP FURTHER THE A HUMAN RIGHT
TO WATER LAW.
AND AB TWO SEVENTY TWO AS WAS
ONE OF THOSE OPTIONS THAT CAME
OUT OF THAT. A DISCUSSION GROUP.
IN ADDITION TO ALL THE REASONS
HE ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
GAVE US AS THE RATIONALE FOR
THIS BILL.
ONE OF THE MORE PRACTICAL
OUTCOMES
IS THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE MATTER
GAINED WHEN A SMALLER SYSTEM
THAT IS TROUBLED. EITHER BY A
LACK OF RUBBLE THAT RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLY WATER
CONTAMINATION.
LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT.
LACK OF ABILITY TO HANDLE
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
IS.
BEING ABLE TO SPREAD THE COST
OF SERVICE
OF OVER A LARGER CUSTOMER BASE
AND.
THAT'S WITH THIS BILL WILL HAVE
A HELP FACILITATE.
YOU'VE GOT PER ONGOING AND
NEEDS FOR CONSERVATION OF WATER
FOR A AS A SIMPLE STRUCTURE
INVESTMENT. A PIPELINE REPLACE A
REPLACEMENT.
WATER QUALITY OF COMPLIANCE ALL
OF THOSE NEEDS ARE GROWING AND.
THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE A
BENEFITS WILL HELP MITIGATE THE
PRESSURE ON RATES THAT. RESULTS
FROM A ALL OF THOSE A AND AT
NEEDS.
.
THEY BOTH.
A GENTLEMAN MENTIONED THE.
OF THAT BARRIER HERE THAT'S IN
CURRENT STATUTE WITH RESPECT TO
THE CITYWIDE ELECTION.
.
YEAH OUR.
VIEW IS THAT
CITY COUNCIL WHEN IT PASSES A
RESOLUTION.
THAT STATES INTO THAT IT IS NOT
IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST. TO
CONTINUE TO OWN AND OPERATE A
WATER SYSTEM.
IT'S FAILING.
AND THAT CITY COUNCIL
REPRESENTS A HUNDRED PERCENT OF
THE ELECTORATE. IT DOESN'T IT
REALLY OBVIATES THE NEED FOR A
CITYWIDE ELECTION ESPECIALLY FOR
A COMMUNITY LIKE AT WILLOW'S
HER.
OR OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE A
FEW THOUSAND PEOPLE FOR THE COST
OF RUNNING CITYWIDE ELECTION IS
IS REAL MONEY IN A GOOD THEY'LL
THE OF ITS MONEY THAT CAN BE. A
BETTER USE FOR OTHER.
OTHER ACTIVITIES.
SO WANTED.
INSTEAD OF REPEATING WHAT
THEY'VE SAID I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE OF WHAT.
AB GO TO SEVENTY TWO DOES IT
PROVIDES AN ALTERNATIVE PROCESS.
TO SETTLE WATER SYSTEM THAT
GIVES THE RESIDENTS OF THE
COMMUNITY MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES
TO ENGAGE IN THAT PROCESS THERE
IS STILL A VERY ROBUST. PUBLIC
PROCESS INVOLVED HERE.
REQUIRES PUBLIC HEARINGS PUBLIC
NOTIFICATIONS
A PUBLIC MEETING TO ENSURE THAT
RESIDENTS ARE INFORMED ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE WATER UTILITY.
OF THE BILL IS NARROW IN SCOPE
AND IT ONLY APPLIES TO SMALL
SYSTEMS THAT'S THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED SERVICE CONNECTIONS ARE
LEFT STORY ARE POPULATION OF A.
TEN THOUSAND OR LESS.
THAT HAS AN ONGOING PROBLEM
WITH DEFERRED MAINTENANCE LACK
OF CAPITAL FOR INVESTMENT ALL OF
THE AND NEEDS I MENTIONED
EARLIER.
IT PROTECTS CUSTOMERS BY
ENSURING THAT THE ACQUIRED WATER
SYSTEMS CUSTOMERS DO NOT PAY
WATER RATES.
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN THOSE OF
THE CUSTOMERS OF THE WIRING
SYSTEM.
SO THEY'LL BE ALTOGETHER.
THAT'S IMPORTANT A
CONSIDERATION.
OF BUILT REQUIRES TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT THE RESIDENTS OF THE
COMMUNITY TO OPPOSE THE SALE.
OF THE SYSTEM TO OVERTURN THE
CITY COUNCIL'S RESOLUTION AND
CONTRAST AS YOU KNOW PROP TWO
EIGHTEEN.
REQUIRES A FIFTY PERCENT.
OPPOSITION TO A A PROPOSED RATE
INCREASE.
EQUALLY SIGNIFICANT THE BILL
DOES NOT MANDATE ANYTHING IT
MERELY FACILITATES BUT VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATION. WHERE THERE ARE
WILLING PARTIES
THE BILL DOES NOT DECREASE
TRANSPARENCY IN FACT IT PROVIDES
MORE OPPORTUNITIES AS I AM
MENTION FOR PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT?
THAN THE CURRENT LAW DOES.
AND FINALLY THE BILL DOES NOT
SUPERSEDE THE AUTHORITY OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS.
OR THAT IN MY CASE THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THEIR AUTHORITY TO
APPROVE CONSOLIDATIONS.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON AB
TWO SEVENTY TWO I THINK IT'S
ANOTHER ARROW. IN THE QUIVER
FOR.
CONTINUE THE MOMENTUM ON.
IMPROVE AND ON STRENGTHENING
THE A HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER LAW
THANK AS OUR GUEST.
IS MOTION COULD HAVE A SECOND.
I'LL OPEN IT UP ANYONE WANT TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR JUST YOUR NAME
IN.
YOUR POSITION.
MORRELL JAKE.
PREVENT ME TO SEVENTY TWO THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE. ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
BOB NICHOLS THAT I WAS THING
DEBORAH VALLEY WATER COMPANY IS
CPUC REGULATED UTILITY AND.
.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL AND JUST
BRIEFLY I WANT TO SAY WE.
HAD EXPERIENCE WITH THE CITY
MONTEBELLO THINK REPRESENTATIVE
THE CITY.
HAD WANTED BE UP HERE WITH THE
WEATHER WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE IT
BUT.
.
DIDN'T EXPERIENCE THERE WERE
THE.
CITY.
SERVED BY FIVE DIFFERENT WATER
SYSTEMS ONE TO SELL THAT THE
PORTION OF WITH THE SYSTEM
SERVING PORTION OF THE CITY THAT
IT OWNS.
BECAUSE.
THAT THE RATES WERE HIGH BE.
.
BACKLOG OF NEEDED REPAIRS WAS.
BIT DAUNTING FOR THEM.
IT IN A LIGHT TURNOUT ELECTION
THE.
IT LOST BY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY VOTES EVEN THOUGH THERE
WAS NO. OPPOSITION TO IT. AND
AND IT JUST.
DOES A LOT OF TIME EFFORT MONEY
SPENT BY THE CITY ON SOMETHING.
THEY THEY ARE STILL HAVING
TROUBLE WITH THIS WATER SYSTEM.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW A SITUATION LIKE
THAT TO. BE ALLEVIATED.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO.
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
SEEN NO ONE. UP THERE IS A
MOTION A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS CHAIR WAS
ONE THE STATE'S A COMMITTEE WITH
RESPECT LAST LIGHTEN THEM SIDE.
MAYBE SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU I
THINK WHILE HELPING.
YES SIR I APOLOGIZE PERSONAL
PROBLEM THANK CHAIRMAN I WOULD I
WOULD JUST ASK.
WILL ANY OF THE WITNESSES AND
AUTHOR.
THE LAST PUBLIC SPEAKER GOT TO
THIS HELP HOW MUCH OF A PROBLEM
IS THIS WE HAVE FREQUENTLY R.
THINGS PUT TO VOTES AND THEY
FAIL. MAKE THE THINGS THAT SEEMS
TO BE OF VALUE OUT OF THIS
TICKET LEGISLATION IS TO. YOU
PROVIDE THAT TO ELECT DECISION
MAKERS WHICH I CAN UNDERSTAND
AND RESPECT TO PUBLIC SUPPORT.
UMP KIND UNDERSTAND HOW BIG A
PROBLEM SINCE. SOLID STATE.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF RECENT.
IT RECENTLY THAT HAVE A FAILED
THERE I BELIEVE THEY'RE ABOUT
NINETY.
ATTENTIONAL.
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THIS BILL AT
LEAST
THEY'RE NOT EVEN NOTIFIED
DEFINED IN THE PARAMETERS THAT
WILL HAVE A RIGHT AND THOUSAND
THAT'S ON SO FORTH.
.
WITH NO SENSE OF THE SCOPE OF
HOW MANY ACTUALLY WANT TO SELL
ARE KIND OF THE DIRE STRAITS
YOU'RE DESCRIBING IT NO EXTENT
DEBATE IT'S ATTEMPTED AND FAILED
AT THE BALLOT RIGHT IT'S EVEN
DIFFICULT FOR US TO. ASCERTAIN
THAT BECAUSE.
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME OF THE
CITIES ARE. ARE INTIMIDATED BY
THE LAW AND BILL IN MAY AND MAY
NOT EVEN WANT TO MOVE. FORWARD
BECAUSE I KNOW. YOU KNOW WHAT
HURDLE LITTLE BEES SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY NOT SURE.
ON THAT WE'VE WE'VE DONE A
LITTLE RESEARCH TRY TO FIGURE
THAT QUESTION NOW.
PIPE AYE.
I BELIEVE IT WILL IF THIS BILL
PASSES WILL BE.
OF THE BEING OF A A SIGNIFICANT
UPTICK.
IN THOSE A LOT OF CONSOLIDATION
LIKE I THINK IT WOULD STRAIN THE
CASE FOR THE LEGISLATION IF
THERE WERE MORE NUMBERS ATTACHED
TO. HOW FREQUENTLY THESE
IMPOVERISHED AND AND DIFFICULT
WATER SYSTEMS ARE UNABLE TO SO
TO SEEK THE RELIEF THAT
UNDERSTANDS FROM THE COUNTY TO
SKILLED DOCTOR WAS TALKING
ABOUT?
YOU KNOW I'M HAPPIEST WITH THE
BILL THE DAVE I THINK THAT WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE CASE FOR
UNDERSTANDING WHAT PROBLEM WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE HOW SIGNIFICANT
PALM THAT REALLY IS. THE OTHER
QUESTION IS I GENERALLY HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT EVER.
A POTENTIALLY SIGNED OFF PUBLIC
ASSETS I'M NOT DON'T BELIEVE
THIS BILL SPEAKS TO A
PROHIBITION TO SELLING TO
PRIVATE ENTITIES THIS IS SIMPLY
GOING TO OTHER. PUBLIC AGENCIES
RIGHT THANKS TO ITS NOT LET'S.
IT'S ANYBODY IT'S ANY
NEIGHBORING SYSTEM NAMING SYSTEM
PUBLIC SYSTEM I'D ANY THE WATERS
IT WHAT COMMUNITY YOU CAN BE
BETWEEN EITHER BY. THE BEYOND
ALSO YOU'RE SAYING THAT THERE IS
THIS BILL WOULD FACILITATE THE%
SALE OF PUBLIC ASSETS TO PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS
OR.
THE PUBLIC WILL HIT A RECORD OF
THE GOVERNMENT OWNS IT
AS WELL.
AND I THINK THAT ALSO PROBABLY
REQUIRE STATUS OF DIGITAL
VETTING PARTICULARLY.
NAVICULAR MY OWN CITY THESE ARE
TYPICALLY PRETTY GOOD JOBS.
THAT.
YOU KNOW FOLKS ARE USUALLY PRE
HAVE ABOUT MAYBE NOT SO MUCH IN
THE CASE OF THE SMALL
JURISDICTIONS THEIR PROPS
TEETERING ON FINANCIAL.
SPORTIMES BUT NOT UNDERSTANDING
THAT AGAIN AND UNDERSERVED
OUTSTANDING WHAT PRIVATIZATION
MAY MEAN.
MOST MYSPACE WITHOUT ARE NOT
FAVORABLE.
AND.
ANY KIND BILL TO LOOK
FACILITATE THAT IN A NEGATIVE
WAY YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHEN BY MORE ABOUT THAT IN THE
PURPOSES OF TODAY'S
CONVERSATIONS CHAIRMAN I'M HAVE
TO FOLLOW THE RECOMMENDATION.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK ON
THIS IN WHICH IS MAKE A PLEA FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO MAKE
SURE VERY CLEAR.
I DON'T KNOW. WHAT THE
OFFICIALS MAKING THE DECISION
THEY GENERALLY MAKE MOST
DECISIONS ANYWAY?
AND AT THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT I
THINK YOU'RE COMMITTEE PERFORMS
CHAIRMAN OF ABOUT YOU KNOW SORT
UNCLEAR ABOUT PUBLIC MEETING
THAT EARLY FOR. OUR FOLKS TO
COME AND MAKE THE COMMENTS KNOWN
ABBAS AND FEW THOSE HEARINGS
OVER THE YEARS THEIR THEIR.
THE PRINT SHALLOW GENE I'M SO
TAKE TO SUGGEST THAT SOMEHOW LOW
IN THE BOTTOM SO I MEAN AT LEAST
OR SOMETHING
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND
AN ASSET YOU ARE EVEN KNOW WHAT
THE CITY OF WILLOW'S WOULD GET.
FOR SOMETHING THAT'S UNDER WATER
AND AND NOT NO PUN INTENDED UP
BUT BUT BUT IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO SURVIVE
AND AND HAVING TO DEFEND YOUR
GENERAL FUND CONSTANTLY. TO PULL
OUT WHEN YOU SHOULD HAVE UNITS
YOU HAVE I SUSPECT YOU HAVE A.
OF FUND ALREADY FOR YOUR WATER
PLANT AND NOW YOU HAVE TO DIP
INTO THAT. RAISING THE RATES.
ARE ALWAYS A CHALLENGE AND AND
I ALSO DO.
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CHALLENGES
OF A CITY.
AREN'T TAKING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS TO THE BALLOT BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T REALLY CAMPAIGNED FOR YOUR
CASE. SO THAT BECOMES AT BECOMES
ANOTHER PROBLEM SO THE FACT THAT
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
PROTESTS COULD OVERTURN THIS I
THINK IS SIGNIFICANT I THINK
THAT'S A POINT THAT'S ONLY A
POINT IN YOUR FAVOR.
AND SO.
BUT I I AM CURIOUS TO KNOW WHAT
YOU KNOW IF WILLOW'S WERE TO
SELL OFF THEIR ASSET YOU KNOW.
IS IT A ZERO SUM GAME OR ARE YOU
OR DOES THE CITY ACTUALLY.
GET OUT AT THE STAND TO GET
SOMETHING FOR THE FOR THE ASSET.
WE HAD AN APPRAISAL DONE
APPROXIMATELY SIX YEARS AGO. AND
THE APPRAISED VALUE WAS AROUND A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THAT WAS BEFORE IT
WAS IDENTIFIED CHROME SIX.
SO AT THIS POINT.
WE HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND A
CONTAMINATED WATER SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE UP AGAINST
AND.
RAISING RATES OR TREATING THOSE
WATERS IS NOT FEASIBLE SPECIALLY
WHEN WE'VE ALREADY PLACED. THAT
GRAMPUS ON CLOSE TO SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF TREATMENT
FACILITIES IN WILLOW'S WHEN WE
CAN TIE INTO THAT SYSTEM AND AND
TREAT AND. PROVIDE THE WATER
DOWN TO THAT SYSTEM THAT'S
TREATED IN AND.
.
SAFE FOR CUSTOMERS.
AND I GUESS I YOU KNOW FOR MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND THAT
WHEN I WAS A AND THE COUNCIL
MEMBER THE CITY FEELS PER WEEK.
WE WERE ARE ARE ONE OF THE FEW
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA I THINK OR
ARE THERE THERE PROBABLY QUITE A
FEW CITIES BUT.
A SMALL CITY TWELVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE OWN OUR OWN WATER UTILITY
OUR OWN ELECTRIC UTILITY R.
WASTEWATER UTILITY OF VERY
UNUSUAL FOR A SMALL CITY AND I'M
WE OFTEN HAD REQUESTS YOU WANT
YOU DIVEST YOURSELF OF YOUR OF
THE ELECTRIC UTILITY. ABOUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY WHEN YOU DO
THOSE CALCULATIONS THE VALUE OF
THAT.
TO THE PUBLIC WAS REALLY PRETTY
MINIMAL AND REALLY NOT WORTH THE
EFFORT CPAS AYE THE FACT THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE A LOWER
RATE TO OUR CUSTOMERS. SO.
WITH WITH A WITH CHALLENGES
THERE SO IT'S A PRETTY AYE I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY I'M
I I DO ECHO SOME OF FUNDS TO
GLORIA'S CONCERN SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE MEMBER YES JUST AN
ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
AYE I SEE THIS A PROBLEM A HUGE
PROBLEM DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THERE AND MAKE MY
CITY IN PARTICULAR WE HAVE FIVE
DIFFERENT WATER AGENCIES
SERVING.
YOU KNOW ONE ONE CITY AND
THERE'S ONE IN PARTICULAR THAT
REALLY SHOULD JUST.
I KALITTA DAY AND.
YOU KNOW THEY JUST HAVE SO MANY
ISSUES BUT.
THIS WOULD HELP.
IN THE CONSULATE THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THAT ONE SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD BUT YOU'RE GONNA
GET A LOT OF CHALLENGES. I
BELIEVE AYE IF
WE EXPAND ON ANY OF THESE.
PARAMETERS BECAUSE THERE'S YOU
KNOW BUT THE WORD HAS BEEN FOR
YEARS AND YEARS THAT ALL THESE
WATER AGENCIES SHOULD
CONSOLIDATE SO I JUST WANT TO
CAUTION YOU. THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF PUSHBACK FROM YOU KNOW BIGGER
AGENCIES THAT ARE.
THERE AND DON'T WANT TO GO AWAY
AND I THINK THE PUSH.
HASBEEN AT SOME POINT FROM EVEN
THOUGH PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO CONSOLIDATE ALL
THESE WATER AGENCIES SIDE ONE
OPEN THE DOOR. UNIFORM FOR
CHALLENGES LIKE THAT'S I JUST
WANNA MAKE FACTOR YOU KNOW JUST
THE CAUTION BECAUSE THIS OPEN
BACK DOOR SOMETHING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION VICE CHAIR.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
.
BUT KNOW FIRST WELL APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR ME OF BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I THINK THERE IS
DEFINITELY.
THAT THIS COULD BE A TOOL BUT
TO HELP LOCAL COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY SMALL AND IN MY
UNDERSTAND IS.
THAT THIS IS REALLY TARGETED
TOWARD SMALL.
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS.
AND MANY OF. MAY HAD THIS
EXPERIENCE IN MY RURAL DISTRICT
WHERE WE HAVE.
NEO PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS THAT
REALLY DISK CAN'T COVER THE
COST.
TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THEM.
AND IN SOME CASES IT'S MADE
SENSE TO YOU KNOW DIE BEST.
FROM THEM.
AND OBVIOUSLY THE CITY OF
WILLOW'S IS IN MY DISTRICT. AND
I THINK A MR PEABODY FOR COMING
DOWN TODAY.
AND IN TALKING ABOUT THIS THIS
ISSUE.
.
I THINK THAT THIS LEGISLATION
COULD BE HELPFUL FOR COMMITTEES
LIKE WILLOW'S WHERE. YOU KNOW
REALLY MAKE SENSE TO DO THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF PUBLIC SUPPORT
FOR. A WHAT I WHAT I THINK ABOUT
IS.
.
YOU KNOW MAYBE SOME SITUATIONS
WHERE.
YOU NEED TO HAVE PROTECTIONS.
.
IN PLACE.
AND WHERE AND WHERE THE PUBLIC
MAY NOT BE SO.
INCLINED TO SUPPORT DIVESTITURE.
.
ONE THING I'D LIKE TO SEE AND I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S SOMETHING YOU
CONSIDERED I KNOW WE'VE. I THINK
THE COMMITTEE MEMBER IT'S MAKING
A TEN DAY PROCESS FOR THE
PROTEST.
.
I THINK WE WOULD NEED MORE TIME
THAT I THINK UNDER PROP.
TO EIGHTEEN IT'S A FORTY FIVE
DAY.
PROCESS YOU KNOW FOR THE PUBLIC
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROTEST IF THEY NEED TO.
AND I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT
MIGHT BE WORTH PUTTING IN HERE
IS NOT JUST THE.
THE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT THAT
WOULD TAKE IT TO AN ELECTION.
.
BUT PERHAPS THE JUST LIKE TWO
EIGHTEEN IF IF FIFTY PERCENT
PLUS ONE.
THAT COME IN AND THAT FORTY FIVE
DAY PERIOD IMP AND PROTEST THE
SALE. THAT THE CELL WOULD NOT GO
FORWARD.
NON THE I THINK THAT BE MORE
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROTECTIONS
THAT WE PUT IN PLACE FOR.
YOUR CONSUMERS AND AND
TAXPAYERS.
.
TO ENSURE THAT SOMETHING'S NOT
GOING FOR THIS GOING TO.
YOU KNOW NEGATIVELY AFFECT THEIR
RATES POTENTIALLY IN THE FUTURE
THAT THINGS LIKE THAT BUT BUT
STILL HAVE THE TOOL IN PLACE SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO DO A
COSTLY ELECTION YOU KNOW I GUESS
IS IS. HERE WHEN HEARING WHICH.
BUT HAVE THOSE PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE AND IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
YOU'VE CONSIDERED AS ABSOLUTELY
MAY WE COULD.
INCORPORATED THE BILL GOING
FORWARD.
MISTER MEMBER ABSOLUTELY.
WE'VE CERTAINLY LOOKED AT THE
FORTY FIVE DAYS AND SO IT WILL
TAKE THAT.
AND AND AMEND THE BILL.
TO REFLECT THAT.
CERTAIN WE'VE BEEN AND
APPRECIATE EACH MEMBER OF YOUR
ARTICULATION OF THE POINTS THAT
YOU LIKE TO SEE AND WE WANT TO
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER AND WE
WILL MAKE THIS BILL BETTER. SO
THAT YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE AFTER
THIS COMMITTEE.
VOTING ON THE FLOOR.
SO DO I AM AND GUIDES YOU AS A
COMMITMENT GOING FORWARD IS A
COMMITMENT GO OKAY ABSOLUTELY
EXCUSE MY VOICE SOME YEMEN
DOUBTS OF THE PACIFIC THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU ESTHER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. SEEN NONE THERE'S
MOTION SECOND FLOOR I SOUND LIKE
A CLOSING. THAT THAT LOS. THANK
YOU THAT SOUND LIKE ONE.
ALRIGHT I'M SECURE PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT BORDER GARCIA. GARCIA AYE.
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
LET ME CHECK OUT THIS
I'M GONNA HOLD OFF ON VOTING
MISTER.
I AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
FINALLY COMMITMENT UNFORTIFIED
BECAUSE THAT WAS MY SERIES OF
QUESTIONS. WHERE I WAS GOING TO
GO?
YES OF SYDNEY.
JUST HOLD UP RIGHT TILL WE GET
TO APPROACH
MR PANETTA UNOPPOSED. SUPPORT.
THANK A BIGELOW NOT VOTING
CORREO.
KOREA AYE CHOI.
CHOI NO. CHU.
CHIU I YOU FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE. GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE.
HARPER. HARPER NO.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE. LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE. MATHIS.
LOVE THOSE. MATHIS NOT VOTING.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE.
SOLIS.
WOULD.
WOULD I.
IF THE MEASURE PASSES MOVES TO
SIMPLY PRO.
OPERATIONS THANK YOU.
I NEXT.
ITEM YOU SOME MEMBER LEVINE.
RIGHT AB TEN NINETY SEVEN
SMOKING MAN AND STATE PARKS.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND DIED AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL THAT
YOU'VE SEEN BEFORE THIS BAN ON
SMOKING STATE PARKS AND BEACHES
WE KNOW.
THE RISK FOR WILDFIRE CANCER
POLICE INTO OUR ECOSYSTEM AND
WILDLIFE AND DIE AND AGAIN.
THIS PAST YEAR OTHER GOVERNORS.
DECIDED TO VETO THE LEGISLATION
AS WE'VE TRIED TO TAILOR.
TO LAUGHTER TO THE RIGHT
BROADER NARROWER AS HIS VETO
MESSAGES HAVE DIED HAVE SENT US
AND THAT WE ARE GOING TO DO IT
AGAIN AND TRY TO FIND THAT SWEET
SPOT FOR GOVERNOR BROWN. AYE
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ANYWHO SPEAKING AND.
FAVOR THE BILL.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVENS WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.GOOD
MORNING AND FOR OTHER OF
THEM THOUGH WITH US SOON CAN
TRANSPORT.
KAREN LET GET IN SUPPORT OF HIS
BILL.
RIGHT ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK.
OPPOSITION OF THE.
I CAN'T MAKE BOB HAVE A
CALIFORNIA'S FOR TOBACCO HARM
REDUCTION IN OPPOSITION.
YOU KNOW.
THE QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE.
CLEAN UP YOUR.
JIM CLARIFICATION BECAUSE THIS
IS A INTRODUCTION OR RE
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL AND I
WANT TO SEE WHAT THE DIFFERENCES
FROM THE PREVIOUS ONE NOT MAYBE.
THIS STILL APPLIES TO ALL STATE
PARKS INCLUDING STATE BEACHES.
YES OF THE THE DIFFERENCE.
IS NOT IN THIS BILL BUT IN THE
PRIOR VETO THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD
WHERE HE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
BROAD THE BILL WAS THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO PROVIDE THE PARKS
DIRECTOR MORE DISCRETIONON HOW
TO. APPLY OR NOT APPLY IT ON.
THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE I PERSONALLY
DON'T YOU KNOW.
AGREE TOO MUCH WITH THAT TYPE OF
LEEWAY BUT THAT.
PERHAPS FOR GOVERNMENT
ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES THERE
MAY BE A RATIONALE TO HAVE SOME
TYPE OF DISCRETION AND SO THAT
IS IN THE LEGISLATION.
GOTCHA SO IT COULD APPLY TO
EITHER BUT IT'S DISCRETIONARY.
AYE THAT'S RIGHT BEYOND DAWN IN
IN TERMS OF.
OF WHAT IT'S INTENDED TO COVER.
IS IT DOES CIGARETTES ONLY IS IT
CIGARS IS IT VAPING HOW WHAT
WHAT IS IT YOU DOES. IT IS SUCH
A BROAD UNIVERSE THAT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE SAY WHAT IS A SUPPLY TO
MARIJUANA AND I THINK THAT I
WOULD SAY THAT'S TOO NARROW
BECAUSE WE. INCLUDE WE'D OR
OTHER PLANT.
AND VAPING AS PART OF THAT
OKAY.
AND SO IT DOES POTENTIALLY
INCLUDE CIGARS ELECT RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFICATION
APPROACH AGAIN WHICH MIGHT BE SO
I PERSONALLY. DON'T.
FEEL LIKE I WANT BUT I KNOW THAT
FROM A POLICY LEVEL IT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE FOR CALIFORNIA.
YAK IS ON THE LAST IMAGE YOU'RE
INTRODUCED UNITED THAT TRY TO
DRILL DOWN ON SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE.
I SOMETIMES IMPOTENCE FOR
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS IS THE
LETTER QUESTION.
I WHICH CIGARS DON'T NECESSARILY
APPLY TO BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A
FILTER SITUACIN.
WITH THE CIGARS BECAUSE IT'S
PRETTY MUCH A BIODEGRADABLE. AYE
AND THEN THERE'S THE SECOND HAND
SMOKE QUESTIONS SOME PEOPLE HAVE
BOTH OF THOSE SOME PEOPLE HAVE
ONE OR THE OTHER. AYE AND SO
WHAT THAT WAS A PART OF WHAT I.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
IT ANOTHER QUESTION OVER HERE
DR.
OKAY YEAH A NOT SPECIFICALLY UP
AT ANY QUESTION BUT I THOUGHT I
AM A STRONG PROPONENT OF A.
SMOKING BAN ASSAULT WHEN ON.
PUBLIC AREA.
INDIA CITY OF IRVINE.
MY.
IN TERMS THAT I HIRED.
ABOUT THE SEVEN EIGHT YEARS AGO
AND THAT HE DID A. VERY IN DEPTH
A STUDY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS SO
AND THAT FOUND OUT THAT THE
SECONDARY SMOKING.
YOU MAY SMOKER AND HER JAW BODY
SO FAMILY UP TO YOU BUT THE
SECONDARY SMOKING THE PERSON
NEXT TO YOU INHALING.
THAT IS ARE SOMETIMES MORE
DETRIMENTAL AND THAT THEREFORE
WE ADOPTED.
NOW KNOW SOME ARE SMOKING ON A
PUBLIC PARKS IN THE.
IT WAS SO UNANIMOUSLY COM
PASSED.
A IN THE CITY OF IRVINE AND THEN
I THINK THAT IS SO ALSO. A SEEM
NOT PRINCIPLE SHOULD APPLY.
EVERYWHERE ELSE IN IN DISCUS
PARTICULARLY IN INTO PEACHES SO
AND ALSO IN THE PARKS AND THAT
WHERE. WE HAVE SEEN.
MANY MANY TIMES OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF. A DEVASTATING FIRE
THAT CAUSING A PROPERTY DAMAGES
SO IN THEIR LIVES.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS. A GOOD
BEYOND THE ONLY THING THAT I'M.
QUESTIONING IS SO IF OUR.
GOVERNOR VETOED.
A WIDOW WITH THE.
LAST YEAR WHEN I WAS HIS.
.
AND UP ALL ON THE NEW GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AWHILE OLD GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF THAT BAND SO YEAH I
GUESS. SO HOW WE CAN.
PROMOTE THOUGH WHICHEVER THE
GOVERNOR IT MAY BE.
SO THAT THEY HE WOULD BE
CONVINCED US SOME KIND OF A A
EDUCATING THIS IS SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT PRINCE POOR. AYE HE
VETO DON. JUAN BUT THIS IS A
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE AND THE
HEALTH ISSUE IN A PROPERTY
ISSUE.
I THINK THAT YOU JUST VOICED IN
FIRST FALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR CHOI FOR RAISING THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE.
I THINK YOU JUST RAISED.
THE ENCOURAGEMENT THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN NEEDS
TO DO THE RIGHT THING BEFORE HE
LEAVES OFFICE.
GOV AND I OWN TO THAT RISING
OPPORTUNITY FOR HIM TO HAVE THAT
BE PART OF HIS LEGACY.
THANK YOU.
YOU WALK.
BEST WISHES.
BARNICLE MOTION THE BILL.
I JUST WANNA ADAM I TOLD THE
STORY LAST TIME ABOUT MY
DAUGHTER. GOING OFF IN THE BEACH
WITH HER PALE AND COMING BACK
WITH A PAIL FULL OF CIGARETTE
BUTTS. AND I THINK A LOT OF US
HAVE HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
HAVING TO PICK YOU KIDS UP.
CRYING DRAG AWAY FROM THEIR
SANDCASTLE AND WHERE THEY'VE
BEEN VERY HAPPY BECAUSE SOMEONE
SITS DOWN AND DECIDES TO SMOKE A
CIGAR. RIGHT NEXT YEAR ON THE
BEACH AND LET'S BE HONEST.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE RANDOMLY
PATROLLING EMPTY BEACHES LOOKING
FOR REPORTER SMOKING THIS IS
GOING TO COME OUT THE WAY COMES
UP IN A LOT OF OUR CITIES WE'RE
GONNA BE COMPLAINT DRIVEN. WHEN
SOMEONE'S CREATING A NUISANCE
WHEN THEY'RE IN A CROWDED BEACH
AND THERE.
I'M SMOKING A CIGAR IN HAND
SUBJECTING CHILDREN AND.
OTHER BEACH GOERS TO SECOND HAND
SMOKE OR SOMEONE'S LITTERING
THIS IS A TOOL THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN USE.
TO TO CRACKDOWN ON THOSE PEOPLE
SO I THINK ANYONE IS WORRIED ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU CAN HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PATROLLING MILES OF.
BEACH LOOKING FOR PEOPLE ARE
SMOKING YOU KNOW THAT'S PRETTY
SERIOUS SILLY WE WE DON'T SEE
THAT WITH IN OUR CITIES WE HAVE
SMOKING ORDINANCES THAT THAT
DEAL WITH PARKS WHEN OCULUS YOU
HERE. BUT IT'S GOING TO BE A
REALLY GOOD TOOL FOR PER.
LAW ENFORCEMENT BE ABLE TO CRACK
DOWN PEOPLE BETTER THAT ARE
CREATING A NUISANCE AND YOU KNOW
MAKE A MUCH BETTER ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL OF US AT THE BEACHES I
FELT VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THIS
BILL LAST TIME I WAS VERY
DISAPPOINTED WHEN IT WAS VETOED
AND I HOPE THAT YOU. HAVE BETTER
LUCK WITH THAT THIS TIME.
IT WOULD.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
BACK I I REALLY ADMIRE YOUR
PERSISTENCE ON THIS ISSUE.
HEAD AS A AS A LONGTIME
ADVOCATE FOR HEALTH AND AND.
AND SMOKING CESSATION I REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT IN OUR
CITY YOU KNOW WE.
WE HAD.
WE BANNED SMOKING IN PARKS AND
AND THINGS VERY EARLY ON IN. AND
WE HAD SIMILAR EXPERIENCES GOING
AROUND OUR LITTLE IN OUR IN THE
CITY FEELS OR HAS A ONE ACRE
PARKINSON PLAZA AND WE. I'M I'VE
I REMEMBER GOING AROUND WITH ONE
OF MY. OF A PHYSICIAN FRIEND OF
MINE.
COLLECTING CIGARETTE BUTTS FROM
THE PARK AND HOW HOW DISTASTEFUL
THAT THAT ACTUALLY WAS AND SO.
SO WE ALSO WHEN WE IMPLEMENTED
THESE BANDS THIS WAS NOT THIS
WAS NOT A GOTCHA THERE WAS NO
DEDICATED OFFICER TO RUN AROUND
IN AND WRITE TICKETS FOR PEOPLE.
USUALLY WHAT IT WHAT IT
ACCOUNTED FOR WHAT WHAT IT MEANT
WAS THAT SOMEONE WOULD SAY YOU
KNOW WE I DO HAVE A BAN ON
SMOKING IN THE PARTY HAS NOT TO
DO THAT AND AND. I DON'T RECALL
ANYBODY PUSHING BACK AGAINST
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY DID THAT SO
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S I THINK
IS COMMON DECENCY IT'S A
FUNDAMENTALLY BETTER FOR
EVERYONE'S HEALTH AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE BRING INFORMED THANK
YOU.
MY.
YOU DO HAVE A.
I RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT'S BEEN
MADE. AB WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
WELL THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR OF THIS
CONVERSATION ARE SUCH PLANS FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ROCCA.
I'M IS TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
NO GALLAGHER NO BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NO CORREO YET KOREA AYE CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE CHU. CHU AYE. FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA AYE GLORIA
AYE HARPER NO HARPER NO.
KALRA.
FULLER AYE LEVINE FLY LEVINE
AYE.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO. RUBIO.
REVIEW AYE SOLACE.
WOULD. WOULD I.
OKAY THE BILL IS OUT.
ON ATTENDED FOR.
VOTE ONTO THE PREPARATIONS THAT
CORRECT.
THANK YOU MUCH THANK MISTER LEE.
AND I WAS THAT WE HAVE NO
FURTHER BUSINESS.
WILL GO HUNDRED YOU'RE IN THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
THE SWEET
.
THE LETTERS ARE FOR XENA.
I THINK